الحب لا يعرف عمرا مقوله شهيره نسمعها
كثيرا لكن يبدو ان العلم لا يتفق معها
اعاده الدراسه حديثه اجرتها جامعه ايموري
الامريكيه اثبتت علميا ان العلاقات التي
تتخللها بعض الفجوات العمريه هي اكثرها
تعرضا لنهايات غير سعيده بالفعل بحسب هذه
الدراسه فانه كلما زاد الفارق بين او
الفارق في السن زادت احتمالات الانفصال
بين الزوجين فالازواج الذين لديهم فارق في
السنب نحو خمس سنوات اكثر عرضه بنسبه
18% للانفصال من المثير للاهتمام ان هذا
الرقم ارتفع الى 39% للازواج الذين لديهم
فرق في السن يبلغ 10 سنوات و95% بالنسبه
الى اولئك الذين لديهم فرق في السن يبلغ
عشرين سنه شاف عادل انا صح الباحثون
الدراسه بتتفق معي الباحثون يرون مشاهدينا
ان السيناريو المثالي يكمن في فارق عمري
لا يزيد على سنه واحده بين الزوجين مما
يقلل من احتمال الانفصال الى ثلاثه في
المئه فقط بلاش
ما هو الفارق العمر المناسب بين الزوجين
لنجاح العلاقه ايش قالوا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للزواج انا ارى السن المناسب طبعا
يكون عشر سنوات اللي بيتزوج يقارب بينه
وبين المراه والزوجه يكون ثمان سنوات وهو
الاحسن والمفيد يعني شو الفارق العشر
سنوات هذا هو الفارق الجيد بين المراه
والرجل وما اعتقد انه فارق كبير يعني
بالعكس والله المتوقع يمكن من ثلاث سنوات
الى خمس سنوات تكون يعني علاقه
كويس عشان يكون التفاهم يعني
والفكر يكون يعني متقارب من بعض
ثلاث سنوات اربع سنوات بينهم والافضل يعني
اللي ما يتزوج
الله يوفقكم اللي يتزوجها اكون عندك وتصير
لك حياه ما كنت متصورها انك تتزوج وحده
اصلا عندك اكبر انا ما تكون اكبر مني بسنه
يعني حتى لو كانت سنه سنتين يعني تكون
بنفس العمر اللي انا فيه او انه اصغر مني
[موسيقى]
يصير كله ضد الرجال ضد الرجال ما يصيرني
غلط دائما
معنا الاستشاريه النفسيه الاسريه لما
الصفدي اهلا وسهلا صباح الخير صباح الخير
تفضلي ونحل المشكله بينكم
احنا نتحدث عن فارق
ما بين الزوجين ودراسه ما حددت حتى من
يكون اكبر الزوج ام الزوجه طيب خلينا نحكي
من ناحيه نفسيه اسريه اجتماعيه هل هذه
الدراسه يمكن ناخذها على محمل الجد بانه
مش لازم يكون في فرق او الاامن علشان
استمراريه الزواج يكون في فرق سنه لا اكثر
اولا خلينا نحكي عن هاي الدراسه وعن فكر
الاهم كمان مشان نفهمها السؤال الاهم هل
يا ترى فقط هو الحب السبب لانه نحن نختار
شريك الحياه لا اكيد لا صح فشو اللي بيصير
باغلب الحالات نحن لما الرجل بيروح بيختار
زوج اكبر كثير منه بالعمر يكون في وراها
اسباب الها علاقه بامه يعني هو بطفولته في
انعكاسات نفسيه واحيانا نتفاجا لما بنشوف
اشخاص نقول كيف 20 سنه وفي اشخاص مشاهير
وعلى مستوى حتى سياسي احيانا بنقول زوجته
بتكبره بخمسه وعشرين سنه ففي خلفيه
اللي بتختار رجل اكبر
يمكن ايضا في
ابويه يعني صحيح وهاي الفكره الدراسه اكدت
انه كل الفتاه اللواتي كانوا علاقتهم مع
والدهم غير علاقه سويه يعني هي عندها
مشاعر غير متوازنه معه بتروح بتختار دائما
شريك بالعمر بيمثل له الصوره اللي هي
مخفيه عندها باللاوعي عن صوره الاب ولكن
للاسف دائما اختياراتهم غلط لانه نحن
بنعرف الزق شو الفكره اللي بيكون عندهم
هاي المشكله ليه لانه نحن بنعرف لما انا
بدي اختار شريك انا ما بدي اياه يكون صوره
عن حدا هو المفروض يكون بيكملني يكون في
مشاعر بيني وبينه يكون انا وياه منسجمين
بالحياه هو ما راح يكمل صوره ابغاء او ام
غير متواجده او شخص عنيف او شخص ظلمني
فبالتالي هاي الزواجات اللي بيكون منشاها
النفسي غير سويه بتكون محكومه بالانفصال
وبعد فتره بتقول بانه هل انا لو رجع في
الزمن انا بسالهم هالسؤال لو انا اعطيتك
اليوم الخيار ورجع الزمن هل بتختاري بتقول
لا فهذه الزواجات اللي هي فارق العمر منها
له اسباب نفسيه ممكن ياثر هاي من جهه من
جهه ثانيه جهه ثانيه فارق العمر كيف بياثر
اللي هو نحنا انا بالنسبه الي بيحكي عن
حالي قبل عشر سنين كان عندي كثير علاقات
اجتماعيه كنت انسانيه نشيطه بحب الزحمه
والضجيج هلا خلاص الاربعين فبالنسبه لي
احتراف على
الموضوع بصير فلتره علاقات اجتماعيه مكان
اقرب الى الهدوء هذا هو اللي بيصير بانه
لما يكون هالفارق في شخص وصل لهالمكان
خليني اسالك بانه الامراه او خليني اقول
بعض النساء حتى لا افتح على نفسي جبهه لا
انت ناوي
الامراه تنظر الى الرجل بانه
الحديث يطول عن هذا الموضوع بحس في بعض
الاحيان في يعني موضوع السيطره يدخل ايضا
في في الاختيارات امعوني النساء اعترف يلا
لما
استشاريا النفسيه الاسريه انت
اليوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات